we've already used a transformation
matrix to transform one point what I
want to do in this video is transform a
series of points and so I have these
position vectors P 1 P 2 and P 3 and
I've plotted them right over here and
you could imagine them to even be
vertices of a triangle that looks
something like this that's one side
that's another side and that's another
side right like that and what I'm
curious about is what would what happens
if I would transform these three points
and like the last video I could apply
this transformation matrix separately to
each of them to see what they transform
into or instead I could take this
transformation matrix I should take this
transformation matrix and multiply it
times a matrix composed of these
position vectors so let me do that
so let me whoops let me take my
transformation matrix so let me copy and
paste that so copy and paste so I'm
going to take my transformation matrix
and I am going to multiply that by a
matrix that has all three of these
position vectors in it where each of the
columns of this matrix is going to be
one of these position vectors so the
first one is 2 comma 1 then we have
negative 2 0 and then we have 0 2 0 2 so
one way you could think about it is
we're taking this we're taking our
transformation matrix and we're
multiplying it by a by a matrix that is
composed of that is composed of the
first column its position vector 1 the
second column is position vector 2
position vector 2 and the third column
is position vector 3 position vector 3
now what is this going to give us well
this is a 2 by 2 matrix 2 by 2 matrix
we're multiplying it by a 2 by 3 matrix
2 by 3 matrix so matrix multiplication
is defined over here because the number
of columns here is the same as the
number of rows here and it's going to
result in a two by three matrix so it's
going to result in a two by three matrix
so two rows and three columns which we
could imagine represents three new
column or three new position vectors so
what's this going to be so let's go step
by step so this first entry first row
first column is this row times this
column so two times two which is four
plus one plus one so it's four plus one
so this is going to be five let me do it
in the same colors so this is going to
be five negative 1 times 2 is negative 2
this negative 1 times 2 is negative 2
plus 2 times 1 plus 2 this negative 2
plus 2 which is 0 so we already see it
transformed 2 comma 1 2 5 comma 0
1 2 3 4 5 so if we consider this p1 we
consider this p1 prime p1 after our
transformation now let's go to p2 2
times negative 2 is negative 4 plus 1
times 0 so it's negative 4 plus 0 which
is just negative 4 and then negative 1
times 2 is positive 2 plus 2 times 0
which is just going to be 0 so it's
going to be positive 2 plus 0 which is
just 2 so negative 4 comma 2 negative 4
negative 1 2 3 4 comma 2 is right over
here so if this is p2 this was P 2 right
over here this is P 2 prime this is P 2
this is position vector P 2 prime or the
position that position vector P 2 prime
would would specify and then finally
let's look at P 3 so we have 2 times 0
which is zero plus one times two so it's
going to be zero plus two or just two
and then we have negative one times 0
which is 0 plus two times two is four so
we get the point 2 comma 4 so 2 comma 1
2 3 4 we go right over here so if this
is P 3 right over here this is P 3
through P 3 Prime and so something
interesting has happened we now have the
vertices you could imagine of another
triangle of a new triangle of a new
triangle that looks something like this
that looks something like this that
looks something like this and so what
you could imagine is actually let me
draw it a little bit
let me draw our new one with this this
blue color here so we can see a little
bit better so we went from we went from
that smaller triangle we went from that
smaller triangle to the larger one this
is the smaller one right over here
that's our smaller triangle to the
larger one or another way you could
think of it this entire triangle was
transformed and right now we only
transform the vertices but it actually
turns out and I'm not proving in this
video that if you transformed if you
took any of these points on this
triangle it would have transformed to a
corresponding point on this larger on
this larger triangle and what's neat
about this is hopefully you're starting
to appreciate what it the power of a
transformation matrix and hopefully
you're starting to appreciate why this
is useful as you start to think about
things like computer games and animation
because what transformation matrices
allow us to do and this is what actual
these computer programs that allow us to
do view things from different
perspectives what they're actually doing
under the covers is they're using
transformation matrices and they're
multiplying them times coordinates in
order to get new coordinates based on
the position or the perspective of the
player or the position or the
perspective of the of the camera or the
the virtual camera in
in a kind of a computer graphics world
so - I guess several neat things here is
we haven't just transformed a point now
we've transformed three points which
could represent the vertices of a
triangle and you see this kind of is
this kind of expansion and rotation that
seems this expansion and rotation that
seems to have happened when we used this
transformation matrix if we use a
different transformation matrix we would
have a different transformation and this
not only did we do it but we saw that we
could do it with multiple multiple
position vectors at the same time I
could have done it independently and
gotten the same result but this is
hopefully starting to show you the power
of matrices and why it also could be
useful and things like computer graphics
and animation and things like that